what a lovely day it is today we are on
our way to go visit Matt's we've got
Matt in the backseat
we finally found out what was wrong with
our poor sweet sweet baby
he has Giardia Johnny Giardia parasite
that is found in there but they also can
get it from eating infected poo or like
from water like sharing contaminated
water yeah and I could have probably
happened at the dog park or really
actually pretty good chance of being at
the dog park yeah are you believing me
now in trouble we both took him to the
dog park
Oh No but it's great because humans can
also have it too but I was reading that
it's not likely that dogs can transfer
to humans but who knows what these
parasites these days they're like
parasites on roids parasites these days
I tell you infection pop
all right Matt be sweet to our dog ready
go
come No well we're off to Marina del Rey
and Renee will hop on a boat law school
well I mean he hasn't moved since
so you pack extra clothes because it's
gonna be a little bit chilly on the boat
but I forgot them but I pack every
single cord
I brought hard drives I brought every
camera alternate batteries but I forgot
my real question is why are you not
playing Shawn Mendes right now yes
you've got a hold of me don't even know
I'm Shawn Mendes your face you're mine
you're a genius
please have mercy oh we're here and
we're about to head off here in
beautiful Los Angeles California Los
Angeles Marina del Rey California Marina
del Rey I think I said you get the point
you know where I'm going Sachin fondo
ready or not this might be yours
baby
[Music]
we can make it count this is what we
waited
if you need help we will but if you
don't but we search if only for tonight
under the sky
we're catching lightning in a bottle
[Music]
windows down to the Sun
maybe tonight we could make it count
this is what we waited for
today
we could make it
we got nothing else to prove no look
I can
[Music]
and
Oh
wanna see
let me see it
let's fire
call
[Music]
we started something I can never let go
I'm
I was just saying in Jenna's vlog that
I'm not sure I've never been on a
sailboat before I'm pretty sure I happen
never let go
[Music]
we don't need
I'm keeping you close
oh sweet
[Music]
it's freezing
[Applause]